.
>> DEMOCRATS, THEY DON'T VALUE
THE TRUTH.
HERE WITH MORE IS SENIOR COUNSE
PRESIDENT TRUMP, FORMER ARKANSA
GOVERNOR MIKE HUCKABEE.
YOU LOOK AT CATHY FOR EXAMPLE I
THAN YOU LOOK AT THE STATISTICS.
THE MURDER RATE, THE CRIME RATE
THE ARSON RATES, THE BURGLARY
RATE, AND WHAT PART OF WHAT IS
HAPPENING IN OUR STATE IS SHE
NOT UNDERSTANDING.
>> I THINK HER BLUNDER ON THE
DEBATE STAGE WAS AKIN TO WHERE
THEY WANT TO MAKE SURE THE
PARENTS DON'T HAVE A SAY IN
THEIR PARENTS EDUCATION.
FOR KATHY TO NOT REALIZE THAT
ALWAYS REALITY IS REALITY, WE
SEE IT'S AN OCCUPATIONAL HAZARD
TO USE THE SUBWAY.
PEOPLE ARE WALKING DOWN THE
STREET BEING RANDOMLY ASSAULTED.
WHEN IT COMES TO CRIME,
PERCEPTION IS REALITY.
THEY RUN A MASTERFUL CAMPAIGN B
PUTTING THE FRONT AND CENTER BY
THE DEMOCRATS COULD NOT WALK
BACK DEFUND PLEASE COME WITH
THOSE OF THE THREE MOST
POISONOUS WORDS SAID BY OF PART
IN QUITE SOME TIME.
LET ME SAY THIS, IT'S NOT JUST
IN NEW YORK AND IT'S NOT JUST A
ARM 80s MAJOR CITIES RUN BY
DEMOCRATS WITH RATES OF CRIME
HAVE GONE UP.
IT'S EVERYWHERE.
PEOPLE FEEL UNSECURE AND UNSAFE
RATE THIS IS ABOUT EVERYDAY
AFFORDABILITY, BUT IT'S ALSO
ABOUT PHYSICAL BORDER SECURITY.
HEALTH SECURITY, ECONOMIC
SECURITY.
IT'S ABOUT ALL OF THAT.
OF COURSE THAT WILL HELP THE
PARTY THAT GOES OUT THERE AND
SAYS NO CASHLESS BAIL.
WE ARE HERE TO PUNISH CRIMINALS
NOT TO PUNISH THE VICTIMS.
PEOPLE RIGHT NOW IN NEW YORK, H
IS REALLY CLOSING THE GAP
BECAUSE HE HAS PUT CRIME FRONT
AND CENTER.
LET'S NOT FORGET THAT THIS
FAMILY KNOWS CRIME PERSONALLY.
HE WAS ATTACKING THE SIEGE.
FIGHT UP CRAZY PERSON WITH A
WEAPON.
SOMEBODY WAS ON HIS PORCH, THIS
IS VERY PERSONAL TO MANY FOLKS.
1994, CRIME IN THE ECONOMY IN
THE CONTRACT.
THEY ARE SO MUCH MORE PERSONAL
AND FRONT AND CENTER.
YOU HAVE THE ENTIRE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY TELLING THE COUNTRY DON'T
BELIEVE WHAT YOU SEE, BELIEVE
WHAT I SAY.
>> GOVERNOR HUCKABEE, YOU LOOK
AT THINGS.
THEY CAUSED A FORTY-YEAR HEIGHT
OF INFLATION.
THEY PROVE IT TO SOAR.
WEIGHT SICK PEOPLE GET THEIR
HEATING BILLS THIS WINTER.
THEY WENT FROM OPEN BORDERS AND
ABANDON THE POLICIES OF DONALD
TRUMP THAT WERE WORKING.
THEY WANT THAT WOKE EDUCATION
VERSUS THE OLD-FASHIONED READING
, WRITING, AND.
THEY WANT THAT DISMANTLE AND
NOBEL LOSS.
THEY HAVE MADE DECISIONS IN THE
CONSEQUENCES ARE NOW EVIDENT TO
EVERYBODY.
IN EIGHT DAYS PEOPLE GET TO VOT
ON WHETHER THEY LIKE THESE
POLICIES OR DON'T LIKE THESE
POLICIES.
ARE YOU BETTER OFF THAN YOU WER
20 MONTHS MONTHS AGO?
I THINK THE ANSWER IS
OVERWHELMINGLY NO.
I DON'T THINK THEY HAVE ANYTHIN
SUCCESSFUL TO RUN ON AND I DON'
SEE A LOT OF SUCCESS FOR THEM I
THIS MIDTERM ELECTION.
>> I THINK WHAT YOU JUST SAID I
EXACTLY RIGHT GREAT IT'S
INTERESTING THAT THERE ARE
STRATEGY IS TO BRING OBAMA OUT
OF MOTHBALLS.
AND WANT TO SAY SOMETHING YOU'L
PROBABLY DISAGREE WITH, BUT I
FIND IT ENTERTAINING THAT OBAMA
IS BACK ON THE STAGE.
HE IS BLOWING SMOKE OUT OF THOS
NODULES AND BOTH EARS IN THE
REST OF HIS BODY AM TELLING A
BUNCH OF STUFF THAT IS NOT TRUE.
TOTAL NONSENSE, BUT I WILL SAY
THIS, IT WAS KIND OF
ENTERTAINING TO WATCH HIM.
AT LEAST HE IS SOMEWHAT FUNNY.
HE CAN PUT A WHOLE SENTENCE
TOGETHER.
IF YOU LOOK ACROSS THE DEMOCRAT
SPECTRUM, THAT'S A PRETTY HIGH
BARBARITY CAN PUT A SENTENCE
TOGETHER.
>> AND WHEN HE'S FINISHED WITH
HIS SPEECH, HE DOESN'T SHAKE
HANDS WITH A GHOST AND HE
DOESN'T WANDER AROUND THE STAGE
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW DO I
LEAVE HERE.
SO IF I WERE A DEMOCRAT RUNNING
I WOULD BRING HIM INTO BECAUSE
THAT'S ALL THEY'VE GOT.
>> I DON'T THINK THAT'S BAD
ADVICE, BUT I'M NOT SURE THAT'S
GOING TO RESONATE.
AMERICANS, IF WE'RE GOING TO
BREAK IT DOWN SIMPLY, THEY VOTE
FOR PEACE AND PROSPERITY.
I CAN'T THINK OF A SINGLE THAT
HAD BENEFITED THE NATIONAL.
TO MEET AT STEP FUNDAMENTAL AND
BASIC.
>> THE BIG FUNDAMENTAL CERTAIN
THING IS THAT MIDTERM ELECTIONS
FOR IS ALWAYS A COURSE
CORRECTION PAIR THIS YEAR, IT
LOOKS LIKE IT REALLY IS A
GENUINE WAVE AND THE WAY I LOOK
AT IT, IF THE DEMOCRATS HAD A
PERFECT NIGHT THEY COULD WIN 54
SEATS AND THE SENATE.
I THINK REPUBLICANS WILL HOLD
ALL FOUR OF THOSE CT ARE.
REPUBLICANS ON A PERFECT WAVE
NOUNS 56 SEATS, A WEEK AGO I
WOULD'VE TOLD YOU I DON'T SEE I
HAPPENING.
I DON'T SEE 56.
NOW I CAN TELL YOU, I THINK
THERE'S ABOUT A 25 PERCENT
CHANCE THAT THE WAVE IS BIG
ENOUGH THAT THE REPUBLICANS END
UP WITH 56 SEATS.
THAT IS WHAT HAPPENS, PEOPLE
WAKE UP SHOCKED.
THEY JUST DIDN'T SEE IT COMING.
IN 2014, THE SECOND UP OBAMA
HELPED US GET NINE SEATS AND TH
SENATE.
NO ONE SAW THAT COMING EITHER.
AS THE THING ABOUT THE WAVE
ELECTION.
YOU DON'T KNOW IT UNTIL YOU ARE
UNDER IT AND THEN THE OTHER
PARTY IS JUBILANT.
>> THAT MAY BE PRETTY HAPPY GUY
A WEEK FROM TOMORROW IF THAT
IMPACT HAPPENS.
>> WHAT YOU SEE HAPPENING?
>> THE DEMOCRATS AREN'T EVEN
TRYING TO SOLVE THE PROBLEM.
THEY ARE ARGUING WITH THE PUBLI
ABOUT WHAT THE.
VINTAGE OBAMA WAS ABOUT HOPE AN
CHANGE, BUT NOW HE'S OUT ON THE
RECOVERY AND RESCUE MISSION.
HE SEEMS LIKE HE HAS A BOULDER
ON HIS SHOULDER, PEDDLING ANGER
AND LYING ABOUT THE REPUBLICANS.
LET ME REMIND EVERYBODY ABOUT
OBAMA'S RECORD HE IS HARDLY THE
CLOSER FOR THESE MIDTERM
ELECTIONS.
ON HIS WATCH OVER EIGHT YEARS,
THERE HAVE BEEN DEMOCRATS LOST
12 GOVERNING SEATS, THE LAST
NINE SENATE SEATS, THEY LOST 95
STATE LEGISLATIVE SEATS, AND
THEY LAST THEY WENT FROM 254-19
IN THE HOUSE 62 SEATS LAST IN
THE HOUSE.
SO HIS BATTING AVERAGE IF YOU
WILL IS NOT SO GREAT WHEN HE'S
NOT ON THE BALLOT.
I ALSO THINK HIS MESSAGE IS TON
DEAF, HE SAID STOP TALKING ABOU
ALL THESE ISSUES, AND THEN HE
GOES OUT AND HE TALKS ABOUT
EVERYTHING BUT THE ECONOMY.
I WAS ALREADY ON THIS I DON'T
THINK A SINGLE REPUBLICAN HOUSE
OR SENATE INCUMBENT WILL LOSE
THEIR THERE ARE A COUPLE THAT
OUR EMBATTLED RIGHT NOW I THINK
THEY WILL BE DRAGGED ACROSS THE
FINISH LINE.
IN 2020 NOT A SINGLE HOUSE
REPUBLICAN LOST FREIGHT WE HAVE
RECRUITED SUCH UNBELIEVABLY
DIVERSE CANDIDATES THIS TIME AN
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY AND THEY
ARE THERE AND NOW THE PARTY IS
INVESTING IN THEM.
SIX DIGIT INVESTMENT IN SOME OF
THESE CONGRESSIONAL DISTRICTS
WHERE BITING CARRY THOSE
DISTRICTS BY 20 POINTS SO
DOUBLE-DIGIT IN TWO SHORT YEARS.
IT'S GOING TO BE A BIG NIGHT FO
IT.
>> I AM IMPRESSED YOU REMEMBERE
EVERY SINGLE ELECTION POST OBAMA
.
IN YOUR RIGHT, HE DID HAVE A
TERRIBLE TRACK RECORD IN TERMS
OF PEOPLE THAT HE ENDORSED
OVERTIME.
GOVERNOR HUCKABEE, BESIDES A
HUGE VICTORY WE BOTH EXPECT IN
THE GREAT STATE OF ARKANSAS AND
A NEW GOVERNOR THERE, WHAT DO
YOU SEE HAPPENING A WEEK FROM
TOMORROW NIGHT?
>> I THINK THAT OCASIO-CORTEZ
HAS NAILED IT PRETTY WELL.
I DIDN'T SAY OBAMA WAS AFFECTED
BY SAID HE WAS ENTERTAINING.
I HOPE HE CONTINUES TO GO OUT
THERE BECAUSE HE REMINDS
EVERYBODY THAT HIS POLICIES AND
THE THINGS THAT HE DID SET UP
FOR THE REPUBLICANS TO TAKE
POWER IN 2016 AND HE MAY REMIND
THEM THAT MAYBE IT'S TIME TO GO
BACK TO THE REPUBLICAN JET AGAIN
.
I THINK THAT'S WHAT WE'RE GOING
TO SEE.
I WOULD SECOND THE MOTION TO
WHAT LARRY HAD TO SAY AND I
THINK HE MIGHT BE SPOT ON.
>> OCASIO-CORTEZ, IF YOU ARE
RIGHT, YOU'RE GOING TO GET A
GOLD SCORE YOU GET THE LAST WOR
PRICKING THE OTHER THING ABOUT
PRESIDENT OBAMA HE ENDORSED
HILLARY WHEN HE WAS A SITTING
PRESIDENT AND HOW DID THAT WORK
OUT.
WAS AT THE HEIGHT OF HIS POWER,
AND INCUMBENT IN OFFICE HE
PLAYED AN ACTIVE ROLE
CAMPAIGNING FOR HILLARY CLINTON
AND DONALD TRUMP ONE.
ENDORSEMENTS DON'T MEAN MUCH IN
THE MODERN POLITICAL ERA.
ECONOMY, CRIME, INFLATION.
IT IS THE WAY THAT ELECTIONS AR
AWARE, BUT WHEN THEY HIT, THEY
ARE BIG AND THAT'S